THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MONICA KLEIN JOINS US.
I'M SURE YOU DESCRIBE YOURSELF
AS PRO CHOICE.
LOT OF PEOPLE THINK OF
THEMSELVES AS PRO CHOICE.
I'M NOT ATTACKING YOU FOR THAT.
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK WHAT DR.
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK WHAT DRN
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK WHAT DRR
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK WHAT DRH
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK WHAT DRM
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK WHAT DRT
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK WHAT DRE
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK WHAT DRG
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK WHAT DRV
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK WHAT DRR
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK WHAT DRO
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK WHAT DRF
VIRGINIA SAID.
THE CHILD IS AN INFANT IS BORN,
THERE'S A POINT WHERE THE MOTHER
AND THE PHYSICIAN CAN DECIDE
WHETHER TO KILL THE INFANTTOR
NOT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> I UNDERSTAND YOU WANT TO GO
BACK TO A TIME WHERE ROE V. WADE
WAS LEGAL AND THEY WERE USING
COAT HANGERS TO HAVE ABORTIONS.
>> Tucker: I'M GIVING YOU TIME
TO MAKE A REAL ARGUMENT.
I'M NOT ARGUING FOR THE REPEAL
OF ROE V. WADE.
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
ESSENTIALLY SAYING.
>> Tucker: PLEASE DON'T BE
TIRESOME.
THE GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA WHO'S A
RISING STAR IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, JUST SAID THIS.
THERE'S PENDING LEGISLATION THAT
MIRRORS IT.
I'M ASKING WHAT YOU THINK OF IT.
>> I THINK THAT RIGHT NOW,
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTHCARE IS UNDER
ATTACK BY THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
72% OF AMERICANS SUPPORT RIGHT
TO CHOOSE.
WE HAVE TRUMP AND KAVANAUGH
TRYING TO RETAKE AWAY OUR
BODIES.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT BABIES.
THIS IS ABOUT YOU ATTEMPTING TO
CHROME WOMEN'S BODIES.
>> Tucker: DON'T BE A ROBOT.
THIS IS THE GOVERNOR OF
VIRGINIA.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU THINK OF
IT.
DOES THAT BOTHER YOU?
>> IT BOTHERS ME THAT ARE
ATTEMPTING TO CONTROL WOMEN'S
BODIES.
YOU ARE.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY RIGHT NOW
IS WORKING OVERTIME TO REPEAL
ROE V. WADE.
>> Tucker: I WONDER IF YOU'RE
UNWILLINGNESS TO ADDRESS WHAT
JUST HAPPENED TODAY ON TAPE IS
SIGN YOU CAN'T DEFEND THIS.
I WONDER WHY THAT IT.
>> AS ON WOMAN, WHAT DO I THINK
IT?
HAVE YOU ASK YOURSELF WHY YOU
SPEND SO MUCH TIME THINKING
ABOUT THIS.
THERE ARE SEVEN STATES THERE'S
ONLY ONE ABORTION CLINIC.
THIS IS ABOUT A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE.
YOU AS A MAN SHOULD NOT HAVE A
SINGLE SAY IN THAT.
>> Tucker: WOW.
DO YOU THINK THAT YOU'RE MAKING
A CASE THAT MOST PEOPLE AGREE
WITH?
THAT IT'S OKAY TO ABORT A CHILD
IN THE THIRD TRIMESTER.
>> YOU CAN KEEP TRYING TO SAY
THAT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
HURTING CHILDREN.
YOUR PARTY IS TEARING FAMILIES
APART AT THE BORDER AND ALLOWING
CHILDREN TO DIE IN FEDERAL
CUSTODY.
WHO'S PARTY IS HARMING CHILDREN?
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU ONE
QUICK QUESTION.
I THINK LESS OF YOU AFTER WHAT I
HAVE TO SAY.
IT'S AN HONEST QUESTION.
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
DO YOU HAVE A REAL ANSWER TO
WHAT THE GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA
SAID OR YOU WILL THROW YET
ANOTHER TALKING POINT AT ME?
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT IT?
>> I HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
I'M TELLING YOU THAT YOUR PARTY
IS ATTEMPTING TO CHANGE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT ROE V. WADE
AND TAKE CONTROL.
AS A MAN WHAT YOU'RE FOCUSED IS
ON CONTROLLING WOMEN'S BODY.
>> Tucker: THIS IS A CHILD WHO'S
BEEN BORN, IT'S NOT A WOMAN'S
BODY, AN INDEPENDENT PERSON.
>> YOU HAVE CONCERNS OVER
CHILDREN WHEN YOU'RE FINE WITH